と思ったらチャンネル登録よろしくね
今日は小学校の先生である私の1日
ルーティーンを紹介します
先生の朝は早いです寝不足でまだ頭が
ぼんやりしているので声を出して体を
目覚めさせます
[音楽]
朝から怒りすぎてしまったのでカルシウム
を取って気持ちを落ち着かせます
そろそろ出勤の時間ですスーツを着ると
一気に仕事モードになりますね
まだ少し眠気があるので生徒を罵倒して目
を覚まします
[音楽]
今日も1日頑張ります
気をつけて
おはようございます
はいおはようそれじゃあ朝6時の時間だ
[音楽]
おいお前なんで
立派な読書ですよ
あるじゃないですか
学校や社会においてルールは敵対です年上
に逆らう子供には無理やり言うことを聞か
せますそれじゃあ今から心のテストをする
ぞ
[音楽]
それでは始め
テスト中は絶好の睡眠タイムです日頃の
睡眠不足をここで補いますうちの学校の
生徒たちはやんちゃですが手が真面目なの
で寝ていても問題ありません
[音楽]
[拍手]
彼らが誤りに来るまで
職員室で待ちます
[音楽]
まあ10分くらいで謝りに来るだろう
まあみんなでいろいろ相談してるだろもう
少し待とう
放棄したせいで勉強できないです
[音楽]
あれおかしいなあいつら先生
です
子供は見た目以上にずる賢いです
手を合わせてくださいおいしい
給食いただきますいただきます
[音楽]
[拍手]
揚げパン食べたい人
だけで決めよう生活
費を犯すためにもらえる給食は全部貰って
おきます
[音楽]
これは負ける
[拍手]
教師としての給料だけでは生活が苦しいの
で
放課後は風船配りのバイトをしています
ありがとう
[音楽]
ございます
副業していることがバレたらクビになるの
でここはうまくごまかしておきます
ようやく自宅に帰ってきました
ですがまだ仕事は終わっていませんここ
から生徒たちのテストの丸つけをします
おかしい
[音楽]
ぞ俺の生徒が全員100点なんてするわけ
じゃないあいつは
大人の目を欺こうたってそう簡単にはいき
ません寝る前は最近ハマってるスマブラを
します
ちなみにこのスイッチは生徒から没収した
ものです
[音楽]
ゲームに負けてストレスがたまったので
生徒を罵倒します
[拍手]
はいうるさい何時だと思ってんだ
すいません
[音楽]
明日も仕事
頑張るか
[音楽]
ちゃっちゃっちゃっちゃっちゃチャンネル
登録チャンネル登録チャンネル登録
よろしくチャンネル登録チャンネル登録
チャンネル登録よろしく最初はチャンネル
登録じゃんけんチャンネル登録またねー